what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host on Sakia today we're
sitting down with Evan Anderson are you
doing not bad thank you for having me
thank you for being on the show really
excited Evan is the CEO of invent IP
which is specializing in nation based IP
theft thank you for coming it's a
pleasure
yeah this is gonna be a blast this is a
more and more growing geopolitical issue
as we get into the technology age yeah
absolutely it's I think more than ever
we see it in the news cycle and so the
awareness of it is increased which is
really good for a long time it was an
issue that was more or less
misunderstood or or in which people were
misinformed about how bad it is and
what's really going on etc so you
actually started me off with a really
good quote just a little bit ago you
said it was the former CIA chief you
know NSA so yeah Keith Alexander used to
run NSA I had a great quote and it's
been used a lot but it's true and it it
helps people understand the issue and
I'll paraphrase here and we're not to
misquote but he essentially said every
major American company or every major
Western company I might add has been hit
by a nation-state actor looking for IP
and the only difference is those who
know that they've been hit and those who
do not and so that is right there that's
enough to really kind of get us started
because that means that it's constantly
happening and that there is people that
know that it's being happened to
happening to them and people that don't
know that it's happening to them and for
those that don't know what's happening
to them typically what that means is
that your creativity is being used
around the world without you earning a
royalty without you approving it might
be being made in some form that you
actually don't think represents your
initial product or service yeah misusing
what you're doing yeah I think a big big
area where we worry about that
right now in this world would be AI and
so you have as as always you have
technologies that I would say our value
neutral and you create them and use them
and it's the use of a technology that
defines the value of the technology in
terms of morality and so when you create
a tool like the emerging technologies
and artificial intelligence you're
creating an ability or a capability to
enact action and who uses that tool and
what action they enact is very important
I think that we have tired arguments in
in the Western world about is technology
good or bad and that's a really silly
question the question should be who has
the technology and what are their
intentions and so we create these things
with this moment of inspiration and this
excitement about all the things that you
could do with it and then other people
get their hands on it so it's early
dangerous world today because we're
creating technologies and not protecting
them and that means that we don't know
who's going to use them in a wife and
for what yep was a Keith Keith Alexander
he's Alexander former say we don't know
who's taking the IP we don't know what
they're using it for what we do know we
do more and more stuff yeah yeah and so
when when did this really become a issue
this IP theft when what year did it well
we saw a massive uptick in the really
beginning in the new millennium so this
is not a new concept at all and
throughout human history but
particularly throughout modern history
IP has been stolen by governments the
the see change that we really saw are
the paradigm shift in the modern era was
that we had a couple things going on
that were that all intersected one would
be the digital transformation that
humanity's been going through which not
only creates a higher volume of data
higher volume of IP more people are
enabled educated creating IP but also we
have a significant access level that
didn't used to exist and
that in combination is a really
dangerous factor for people who are
creating interesting things and trying
to protect them what we saw was a
massive uptick in amount of data being
exfiltrated which is in part a story
about cyber theft and the emergence of
state actors that were incredibly
capable and in the cyber world but also
the scale of nation sponsored IP theft
which is more a programming question and
that was coming out of the PRC and so
they've built a much more robust system
yeah which is the People's Republic of
China who who now have in their
government a more robust system for
nation-state theft than we've ever seen
in humanity before so those two issues
have kind of combined to create a
perfect storm for those who would create
and innovate and try to protect their
innovations from infringement or theft
so in the early 2000s we saw an uptick
in this and what exactly was going on in
the People's Republic of China what is
what are what is this nation based IP
theft how does it actually work how do
we know that they're talking to each
other and they're trying to find Western
innovations to bring China and just rip
off completely how do we know right and
that's a big question it's it's the most
important broader strategic question
related to this issue and and our
perspective which I deeply believe is
true and I think we're we're seeing more
and more evidence of as time goes on is
that this is a question of national
business models and by that I mean if
you look at any company you look at
their business model to figure out what
are they doing how are they going to
make money and that's exactly what you
do when you're running a company or any
effort honestly if we look at it in a
more creative broad way any effort has a
model and you're creating those models
and in the case of making money it's a
business model for how am I going to
create this how much will cost Who am I
going to sell it to etc nation-states
are the same way and so we don't use we
didn't we didn't use to think about it
that way and we had a lot of isms that I
think are now no longer useful or
passing but now we're looking at more of
a question of around the
if you look at the composition of an
economy of a country that's how they're
making money right am i selling produce
am i creating things in Silicon Valley
or in you know the major industrial
centers of the world that will be new
products or new technologies and selling
those what is it that I do in order to
successfully make money as a country and
we see a major split where it's yeah how
do we make money as a country and then
if you see innovation from around the
world you're like we need to make money
here so what better way than to take
that innovation of creativity right so
we see a split now between models of
innovation driven economic growth and
theft driven economic growth there's
there's many reasons to steal of course
it's very profitable it's much easier
than trying to innovate but it's also
incredibly damaging and tends to remove
that incentive for innovation that that
others have around the world and so
that's our major high-level concern is
that not only are you harming the
companies that are most innovative but
you potentially are reducing the
incentive for anyone to try in the
future I mean how many startups were
four guys in a garage who were at risk
of being extremely broke and very hungry
if they were not successful how many
people are gonna take that leap and say
I'm gonna start a company I'm gonna
build this product that I had you know
the the genius idea for if they're
afraid that they'll get completely
knocked out in the first round so the
greater fear in the context of this
conversation is that if we don't handle
this issue we'll lose that yes and in
losing that we've got some really
philosophical problems climate change is
a perfect one what are we gonna do about
those issues if people are afraid to
create new products and new technologies
yeah that's that's that's a huge take
away this yeah impeding creativity
because I no longer think that it's
worth being broken starving and hoarder
- actually all that right all that ramen
will I really live off of ramen for
three years yes is the hustle no longer
worth it when you get knocked out in the
first round right and that's a big fear
because you know we've we've talked a
lot about Till's book zero to one and we
had George Gilder on the shows and the
idea of zero to one is so important
actually being able to make something to
one in the world and then when it goes
from one to many that's that horizontal
that's globalization that's when someone
sees the idea and either legally brings
it to their place in the world or
illegally bring to their place in the
world an iteration is critical I think
that we tend to focus in America
particularly in the United States on the
the brilliance of the zero to one moment
being the only important thing and I
think that we don't give enough credit
to all the people that work very hard to
take something and make it better every
day
yeah a lot of fortunes and a lot of
human progress
comes out of that process yeah so
iterations are important but also new
technologies are critical and so I don't
think that we should split split hairs
they're too much but I do think that
that we need to understand things in in
a spectrum and so we tend in the Western
world to do that binary and that's not
the only valuable perspective all right
we should also be paying attention to
who's creating a better X and protecting
them and so that we we see the ecosystem
as a whole at any moment could take the
product that we have here in the US and
and legally enhance it - um sure yeah -
and that could be great and in a good
business environment that's what you
want right people talk about well I do
want competition in some ways then
that's exactly the kind of iterative
process where you're you're towing off
against each other or teeing off against
each other that's that's important - but
it has to have rules if there are no
rules to the game it's not gonna be a
fun game to play right so and that looks
very much like those consequences we
were talking about where people are
disincentivized let's let's let's go to
the how do we know that nation based IP
theft is occurring right so when this
first started to come up as a public
issue at least there folks in the
government that are responsible for
tracking this and and a lot of them work
very hard
no well I mean they won't tell you
there's plenty of people that are trying
to track and and deal with this issue in
in governments here and in governments
not just in North America but all across
Europe and worldwide can tell me if this
is not okay to talk about but that's
fine but no but the that there are
people that are from China that are in
the u.s. that speak English there yep
low in the US that are in China that
speak Chinese Mandarin that are kind of
these agents in these countries
observing the way that governments and
businesses are operating yeah and I mean
you know we we know that right we know
there are spies and so the question here
is not so much do people spy on each
other government to government because
we know that always happens right of
course they do the question is why and
so if you're trying to watch your your
either your adversary or your allies or
other just any other countries in the
world what are you doing with that
information and that's where this
difference lies is every country that
has any budget at all will have an
espionage service in order to monitor
the goings-on of other countries and
governments that's more or less to be
expected I mean we have an entire
infrastructure worldwide where embassies
are used for that and they more or less
play games of cat-and-mouse with each
other and the whole point is that
everyone needs to have some sort of
global understanding of what's happening
in order to see their place in the world
and how they're doing and many many
things right I mean that's a whole whole
world of its own what's really important
here is that if you take that
infrastructure in a large country with
essentially blank checks and large
numbers of people and many many
resources and apply it to attacking
companies those companies can't fight
back and they like to talk about the
ways that they're trying to and that's
kind of a matter of not being the tall
nail but if you divert all the resources
of an espionage infrastructure in a
major country pointed at a company how
long is that company going to be able to
keep you out not very long right so
sometimes they're really successful and
we're all amazed that they spent years
under full attack and managed to stay
safe but you know there's just very very
little chance that you're going to be
able to fight off on essentially an army
of a country as a company you just don't
have the budget and so one of the
reasons that my role is important and
one of the things that I think is most
important about my work is that we can
always help each other in the security
sense to to understand these issues and
to be aware and to not just be an open
book and to be to be safer than before
but safer than before and safe are very
different things and so those steps that
we need to take are critical in
companies and in organizations even NGOs
right to protect the information that
we're gathering is critical but what we
really also need is long term policy
shifts that restrict the incentive that
foreign countries have to steal IP in
the first place because you can't change
an economic problem with random
technical solutions in any given moment
if there's an economic incentive you
need an economic solution and that looks
like restricting market access for
thieves right so when someone steals
technology and tries to sell it back to
you you should look at them and say no
that's unacceptable
and increasingly we're doing that around
the world so that's another thing that
I'm very encouraged by yeah stealing the
technology and trying to sell it back
across the world right declining that
okay then you mentioned the importance
of education mm-hmm in the conversation
so there seems to be a push towards
safety then in in as close to safety as
possible but it takes a long time to be
able to throw it off all the espionage
forces that might be occurring to a
company and excuse me and it's very
difficult time-consuming resource
consuming yeah to do so it's a drag on
companies right when you think about how
many resources increasingly so have to
be diverted from what might be an R&D
budget right it could be anything it
could be something that was really
valuable to humanity that didn't get
funded within a company or than a
government because we were distracted by
this more or less infighting between
nations and so that's that's certainly
not the world we want to live in I don't
think that's taking away from innovation
yeah yeah that any time you're spending
resources excessive amounts of money or
whatever it may be people time man-hours
and just
building you know security teams that
have to spend 24/7 active monitoring you
know spend all their whole their time
focusing on keeping the organization's
safe you've lost the ability to put
those people on a different project and
so I'm not saying that the security
industry is a waste it's critical right
but it's too bad that that's the world
we're living in no sense crying over it
but but doing something ism thats an
interesting the part of our
globalization conversation as well as
well we build enough trust with each
other to where we can have many trade
and more love and care across these
artificial borders I'm moving forward
and hopefully we do can we go back to
the People's Republic of China let's
let's I talk about what has been going
on specifically is that can we talk
about some specifics over the last like
15 years yeah I mean I think the best
way to help viewers understand this
issue is also case study so I can throw
out a couple of those right what we one
of the things that we do is collect
public case studies and so I was telling
you before we started here that there's
a there's an old statistic that I
believe still holds true which is that
and it relates to Keith Alexander's
quote which is that out of a hundred
percent of the theft that's occurring
that's from nation-states that's
sponsored by nation-states only ten
percent of it is actually known that
number may have increased in the past
few years but the while our security has
increased in many many global companies
so as the the capability of the
adversary so right it's an arms race and
it always will be but ten percent of
those cases are known by the companies
and only ten percent of those cases are
actually publicly disclosed so we love
to see cases publicly disclosed it can
be very difficult for companies to do
that without for instance losing stock
value but when they are disclosed it's
very important because the public can
understand the issue and without public
understanding we won't get the kinds of
policy solutions we need we won't get
the kind of funding we need no one that
is a politician in a democracy will be
able to justify what they're doing if
the public has no conception of what's
going on I have a case that I like to
cite that was actually in the Seattle
area
and it's very representative of how this
works so there's a company called wick
quick get to that case but absolutely
this is just coming back out of a
hundred percent of all nation based IP
theft only ten percent is known so that
means 90 percent is going unknown right
yes unknown unnoticed you have known
unnoticed and then out of that 10
percent that is known only 10 percent of
that actually it's communicated to the
public rightly so that's so when you see
a story in The New York Times about this
right and you say wow that's a really
blatant case of theft I can't believe
that has like 99 other ones I've just
waved there's 99 other ones that you
didn't hear about that that companies
are looking at or the government is
looking at right and then there's again
that's only 10 percent of the this crew
this seems to be your theft that's going
on in the world more and more important
for the public to be educated about it
yeah to get more creativity and
innovation ok let's go to the other
Seattle well so a good example of this
is there's a company called Huawei that
many people now have heard of it's a
major telecom in the world they used
Huawei made the Nexus Nexus a 6mm x6p
for Google Huawei is I think one of the
largest Asian companies yeah I think
they now have 60 percent of the global
telecom equipment sector since the
market shared the global telecom well
think about who their competitors were
before they started selling such cheap
technology Nortel gone cisco has moved
out of that sector increasingly because
they were facing off against these guys
who are literally selling their own
routers Jami yeah there are there issues
Yummie well let's uh let's get this case
study out so people can kind of see how
this looks and then we'll we can get
into more of it there there are many
different examples but what weighs a
classic people use it as an example
because if I tell you this is a viewer
you can then go and look and actually
find all these cases and there there are
many under always built publicly
disclosed cases of theft but one of the
most flagrant and and I think
instructive ones was in the Seattle area
with
mobile so while I was working with
t-mobile because they were producing
phones and t-mobile was going to sell
their phones and so they had to test
them in the lab before they put them out
to make sure they're up to standards and
t-mobile had a proprietary technology
that they called it's kind of cute Cappy
that tests the smartphone screens the
touch screens so tapi had a little human
finger simulating robot that would check
smartphone screens to make sure they
were essentially up to snuff
and while way was supposed to come in
and test their phones in the in the lab
and and the t-mobile has in the Seattle
area and they had a couple employees
that were cleared to come into the lab
t-mobile I think had very good security
and so these guys came in now what they
really wanted was the taffy technology
right they wanted to be able to do that
themselves because then you don't have
to deal with any of this you can just
test your own smartphones and you don't
have to talk to t-mobile anymore so they
went into the lab and this was all
public you can you can google this they
went into the lab and they brought a guy
from Beijing who was not supposed to be
there and t-mobile knew this and they
said you know these are the guys you can
bring in so here's your security
clearance cards you can scan into the
lab they they counterfeited one of the
cards for this guy brought him in came
into the lab physically broke the part
off of the robot and stuffed it into one
of their bags now tmobile has a security
apparatus that their R&D labs this is
happening on camera right and then they
they book it and so the the folks call
the wall way guys shortly after they've
left and they say so did you just come
in and break a part off our robot and
take it and run away and the guys say no
no we wouldn't do that
of course t-mobile was on to them and
and called the authorities and so by the
time they caught these guys which was
not long after they were already in
their hotel room on a video call trying
to take measurements of the robot with
engineers back in China who were going
to reverse-engineer the product so
that's how flagrant it gets right people
often kind of don't believe me and so if
you actually just start looking this up
right it's it's it should be out of a TV
show or something it's really it's
really flagrant that's not the only case
like that there have been a number of
cases like that that are public so if
you start looking it up you had guys
that were caught you know dick stealing
corn seeds from testing fields in Ohio
or Iowa I'm sorry there are there's
countless cases like these and if you're
talking to companies they've got many
under their belt often if they have a
good security team so they're constantly
watching things come in either into
their network or physical physical
attacks like that on their IP and
they're having to deal with them so it's
a very difficult world to protect your
IP in because these guys operate with
such impunity often it's it's great that
we have made many strides in actually
prosecuting these cases stopping these
guys but I worry particularly about the
startup community and smaller companies
because they don't have the money
necessarily to deal with this so my
suggestion is always if you are a
start-up you can at least have the
awareness and you can seek help from the
outside and you may not have a huge
budget but if you're not aware of the
basic problems and the basic things that
you need to do and the steps you need to
take then you're in trouble because
these guys are out there and they're
looking for you if you're if you think
that it's a matter of self-respect right
if you think that what you've created is
great or even good and valuable odds are
they think so too right they believe you
they don't think you're lying if you're
out there pushing a product that you
think is great they pay attention to
that and then they come find you I don't
want to scare anyone but yeah those are
really nuts and there's economic
incentive behind people to go it's a lot
of money to process yeah so if you go
and succeed with ripping the part off
yeah or going and stealing the seed from
the farm and bringing it home and then
they successfully test it and then Janee
reverse-engineer it then you're making a
good amount of money right it's this
economic incentive it's well you can
actually calculate theirs yeah you can
calculate if you're if you're an
inventor or creator you can calculate
how much money they're making because
you know how much you hope to make right
and so and you know how much you spent
and so if I've got a robot right well
not only do I have a very long period of
history in which little pieces of that
had to be invented to come together to
create the ability to build the new
thing
whatever it may be so that's sometimes
if you really think that could be a
hundred years of progress and study and
research and some of its
government-funded I mean there are many
parts to that puzzle but once you create
the product as as a company or even just
an individual you know how much money it
costs how much effort and how difficult
it was to create that product that's
what they get when they steal something
right so in these that's why the Chinese
government wants these technologies to
be stolen because they don't want to go
through that really complicated
iterative process with many many
failures along the way that's so so very
difficult to achieve they save a lot of
time by just skipping ahead and that
leap frogging seems to be actually okay
in some respect as well if if we were to
be a little bit more open in this
globalization honest trustworthy we were
building stronger relationships with
each other yeah there's a potential
world that you could envision where we
would be sharing things and I think
there's a lot of great stuff going on an
open-source that that focuses on that
and I think we talked about this before
when we met but I have no problem with
open sourcing right of course not people
ask me that sometimes as though I'm you
know the IP monster yes of course not if
you want to if you invent something that
you think is great for Humanity and you
want people to share in that and to
collaborate and work on it that's great
but what it means is that you already
did that calculation in your mind that
you're going to be able to sustain that
you can give that away you're not going
to go broke your family won't be hungry
because you have a different plan in
mind right so people choosing to
disclose intellectual property is very
different and the only thing that I
would say that that worries me about
open source stuff would be just be
careful what you've created be mindful
of what you've created and when you do
open source things just do a double
check in your mind what could this be
used for
so am I giving this to someone who you
know if it's free to the general public
that can be really great unless they
decide again to use that tool for a
nefarious reason don't forget that there
are people with different goals than
yours out in the world
right I want to say that I envision a
world where it's more collaborative and
but it's still competitive people are
still competing for creativity and
innovation but at the same time once
they create it if other people want to
take that one and make it a 1:1 or a
one-two we do it legally right we have
rules I mean there are many different
very very interesting programs today
where even sometimes not very often but
sometimes major companies work together
is happening with some some interesting
renewable technology you see these
companies coming together to like for
instance two car companies might band
together to help both of you know to
work together to create electric cars
and they wouldn't be able to have the
budget separately I mean there are a lot
of different ways that we can
collaborate around the world we just
have to be careful about what the rules
are and can we can we enforce them well
let's take the tapi example for example
so if my company wants
tapi and I ask t-mobile for a license to
use their technology of tapi and
t-mobile says no yeah then I'm like well
I'm Sol now I'm well you're not I gotta
go innovate it myself just may need to
do your own homework yeah exactly I mean
if I wanted your refrigerator and I
asked for it and you told me I couldn't
have it it would not be acceptable for
me to break into your house with a
couple of my friends and take it right
because otherwise I don't have a
refrigerator I mean this applies to any
any basic you can just boil this down to
you yeah right what happens when you
don't get what you want well you're not
allowed to just rub people that's good
it's not yeah that complicated right at
the end of the day it's so funny how
it's different with IP though than it is
with the fridge or it seems to be
different it feels more important to
people I think and so if you're a
company that's trying to innovate and
you feel that there's a piece that you
need and you can't access it that can be
very frustrating yes
that's kind of not where I live and
that's fine that will always be an issue
and so
it's never great I don't think to have a
new technology be completely monopolized
by a single entity but okay there also
needs to be a reward to spending all
that time and effort right and so you
can't you can't just break all the rules
and expect to have a good world because
who's gonna spend all the money on an
initial investment if it's not protected
so a company will innovate and create
and then there will be some sort of
ability for them to make a good amount
of impact and money on their on the IP
and then when other people ask hey can
we use your IP like for example let's
say with Facebook's data or Amazon's
data or whatever soon and hopefully
there will be these horizontal
marketplaces of data rather than these
vertical ones but let's say that then
the doors do open up for that data to be
used for good purposes again using a
tool for good rather than bad it's
difficult to to know when that's when
that's the case but if they do open it
up then let's see how we can move
forward into the future where I P
becomes something that can be shared
that can be rewarded the creativity can
be rewarded and then the ones can turn
to one point ones one point two is
across the shirt yeah and if you if you
took that as a value set as long as you
kept in mind that there are negative
actors in the world you could easily
push for better legislation and I mean
there are many detailed things that you
can do in the world to make goals like
that more possible while protecting
people and I think a common refrain that
I have in my mind and I think it's it
should be true about things like
education and things like doing doing
work in an NGO that has a good goal is
that good people should be able to make
money doing good things and I think we
can build that world I don't think that
that's somehow an oxymoron right it's it
should be easy and we want to create a
system that facilitates the fact that
people can take their creativity and
their ingenuity and do great things for
the world and invent new things and
wonderful products that are very useful
or change the nature of who we are as a
species even without kidding targeted
right and so that's kind of that's
that's what we do is is we try to create
that world
alright let's is there something else
that we should talk about regarding your
work before we ask you a couple
questions I mean I think we've we've
done a good overview so if we were to
distill it down to some simple points
for for any viewers this is a really big
problem it has been for a long time but
now there's actual consistent media
coverage so you'll see more of it that
doesn't mean it didn't exist before it's
really really critical that we do
something about it we can't just sit
there wondering what to do scratching
our heads so it's a it's a major global
issue that needs to be solved we can't
have nation-states targeting companies
it's just going to be a bad bad scene it
will the world will not be a nice place
to live in if that's a consistent an
ongoing project - it really is as bad as
people say so you will you will see
cases that are super flagrant very very
ridiculous at times and that's just an
illustration of how aware we need to be
so increasing awareness is the immediate
response that you can that you can enact
tomorrow both as an individual and as a
company and there are many people that
can help you with that we certainly help
people with that there are many other
people who understand this issue and so
don't get to doom and gloom don't get
too afraid there are things you can do
even in the short term and three join us
right so help us get those long term
solutions in place
that will protect things that that need
to be protected and that will create
that future that you kind of we're
pointing at where where innovation is
valued and protected and people do
collaborate and there's a set of
international rules and norms that
facilitates that so you know that would
be your immediate medium term short term
and long term on this issue I think as
you were talking I also thought about
how excuse me for a second
I also thought about how how back in the
day when we were first inventing things
really thousands and thousands of years
ago there was a tribe that had made
something that showed it to another
tribe yep and then the other tribe was
like oh that's so interesting and there
was no such thing as IP but was there
also a tribe that had made something
that didn't want to show it to the other
tribe and then was attacked probably
right yeah so you know all of a sudden
they were attacked by them right yeah I
mean I you can easily envision how this
would have played out pretty much from
day one of human history and why we
instead of clubbing each other over the
head for intellectual property ought to
have a set of rules that people agree to
follow internationally yeah yeah okay
there's so much more to unpack on this
conversation then well so what we'll put
oh let's let's put a pause on it for now
hopefully we can do another session one
year when you're in town that'd be great
how about we ask you a couple questions
what do you think all of this has to do
with wealth being concentrated in the
hands of just a couple people in the
world and then all of this information
technology exacerbating that wealth
inequality what do you see that future
going how do we mend well I think we
often talk as a society about where we
see it going now and I'm not here to
disagree with the fact that wealth
inequality has gotten completely out of
hand in the Western world and it has
always been out of hand and modern
history and the in the broader world I
think that there are many things that we
can do about that and so we need to deal
with that problem it's not really
optional because we've seen in human
history what happens if you don't deal
with that problem yeah so I don't care
you know how tall your fortress walls
are if you if you abused the population
at large then bad things tend to happen
and so I think any leadership in any
country should understand that it's it's
not a lesson we need to repeat we're
smarter than that
so solving those issues I'm not an
expert on that but there
people who study that and there are many
positive solutions sets that have been
enacted in the past what well I think is
potential I think that there are
countries all over the world that have
reduced inequality and so if you're not
able to do that the first thing would
obviously be the first thing to do would
obviously be to look at those models and
I know this is a tired more but Europe
doesn't have the same level of an issue
with this as North America depends too
so this is not unsolvable there are a
lot of issues like that in the world
word there are there are certainly
things that you can try and I think we
have a problem in North America and
particularly in the United States of not
trying yet and that's very different
than it being intractable as an issue
that being said I'm not saying it's easy
so this you know we're into my personal
opinion but yeah that that's an issue
that just simply has to get dealt with
in my mind it's not optional and so I
think we we have many things that we can
try policy wise and we can get a
domestic policy guy in here next time
and talk about that as it relates to our
issue it's a really good question
because I think people tend to again to
see things in black and white too often
particularly in this culture and one
question that I sometimes get is well
are you just trying to protect a system
that is creating wealth inequality and
that's not at all the point because as
you were as you were saying there are
parallels to IP what we now call IP a
throughout human history and while while
things should be shared in order to slow
wealth inequality I don't think that
having no rules is the right answer
right I don't think chaos is the
solution to a system that needs tuning
so I think that we have very clear
policies that have exacerbated this
problem particularly in the United
States and I think that we therefore
should be able to start doing our
homework on how to on do some of the
things that we've done
I just I just I can't stop taking all
this off my mind because it's such an
issue across the world mm-hmm and now
not only wealth inequality but also
globalization those two things smash
together I feel like I are potentially
going to cause a destabilization I think
they already are if you look at the the
global political atmosphere today I
think that there's a lot of fear in the
world based on this clash based on
witnessing the clash between
globalization and the kinds of systemic
differences that I was discussing
earlier the kinds of cultural
differences and an economic and national
business model differences between
different poles of power around the
world we kind of got into this earlier
but globalization sort of gets thrown
out a lot as this broad generic thing
and and people again do a 0 to 1 right
is it 0 or 1 is it a good thing or a bad
thing right and that kind of question
gets post constantly and I don't think
that's the right question multivariate
is very important to stay economists
when talking to people about it it's
very important to hold longshore
positions new positions across all the
different variables okay let's go do do
you think we're alone in the cosmos haha
well that's a fun one yeah no I don't
and then why just statistics simple
statistics so yeah I certainly would be
in the camp that if we're if we're gonna
actually honestly look at how many
potential realities there are there on
other planets then it's pretty hard to
believe that we would be entirely alone
in terms of some sort of organization
that we would probably call life do you
think that there's spacefaring
civilizations ones that roamed the
cosmos I mean I don't know but I would
love to know about them if they're out
there right so I think that that defines
that humans search that we've had for
most of the modern most of modern
history and I certainly would say yeah
let's fund these programs and go look
around I don't know why you would be
sitting in a neighborhood as large as
ours and not you know go check out
what's out there so
think we're in a computer simulation no
I don't think we're in a computer
simulations basically I think that
that's more of a thought experiment -
yeah I think that I think that that's a
great way to think about things in order
to try to remove your frames and not not
be such a biased mind which we all are
naturally right so we constantly I do it
in my work many other people do it in
different lines of work you have to
remove the frames that you want to see
through that your brain says see it this
way right we're that's how human
psychology works you build over time on
on previous experiences and so those
biases are very useful but you also
ought to spend some time taking them off
and and looking at things with new eyes
if you can in there they're all ways to
kind of practice that right and it helps
you see reality much more clearly
sometimes and so I think that the the
concept of being in a simulation is very
helpful in that way but I don't think we
should get too literal about it because
we're you know no information right so
the fun part is since we don't have
information what is that what would that
mean if you open to it
it's happen to figuring it out some way
now before we may in the future or maybe
when you die you'll see a big game over
screen 3 - no yeah I don't expect to see
that screen yeah I think I'll slide into
some sort of ether how about what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world you should have warned me you're
gonna ask a question like that the most
beautiful thing in the world I'm tempted
to say that it would be something along
the lines of love or sharing right but I
think on the spot here what makes those
things exciting that we truly value
usually across the species is also
highly related to the excitement of
great feelings and great experiences and
so I think excitement relates a lot to
innovation as well all right I'm gonna
live feeling alive right what is that
what what makes us feel alive well I
think excitement is a huge part of it
and that is the state of being that many
of us chase in different ways
and find most rewarding and and you
could relate that to you know physics
concepts as well I think animation and
excitement are encompass some of the
most beautiful things in the world what
is something that you believe to be true
that nobody else believes to be true hmm
the no one else believes to be true how
would I know or very very very rarely is
believed to be true I think my work for
a long time has been that so that's
changing now but my normal answer would
be well there are foreign governments
that are robbing companies around the
world and doing it with reckless abandon
at times and no I'm not lying right so
so hopefully that will change and I
think it is changing but traditionally
in the last few years that has been
something I not only believe but know to
be true that many other people did not
believe to be true Wow with that I want
to tell you thank you yeah thank you for
joining us on the show I want to thank
everyone for tuning in if you thought
that this content was useful please give
it a like give it a comment give us a
subscribe smash that subscribe button
join the family join the simulation team
share this content this is really
important stuff how do we enrich the
world with more creativity and more
innovation how do we do it in a way
that's friendly across borders how do we
work together on that let's have these
discussions with more people join us on
patreon we need to keep the studio
running we need to keep all the
operations rolling so join us there
please and we'll catch you guys more
soon they start producing partner Ron
Vargas peace
[Music]
[Music]